dr franco you yourself
spent three years in four german
concentration camps during world war ii
uh it's been said that you came out of
the concentration camp with your new
theory
could you this is not exactly the
the truth when i entered the
concentration camp of auschwitz i had
the full length book manuscript of my
first book that later
was published new country under the
title of the duck and the soul
i had this good manuscript in my pocket
but of course it was confiscated
but after the war
i rewrote it and i even believed that
this might have contributed to my
survival
the odds were very poor three percent of
those who
came to auschwitz together with me
survived but i think this might this
strong desire to rewrite my book my
life's work as it were
might have added to the chance that the
poor chances
to survive because the will to meaning
has a survival value as this term
reads in american psychology does this
survival value that you speak of hold
only for individuals and
special circumstances you may amplify
this i believe that this not only holds
for
men but also for mankind as a whole
and i think uh the lesson
i had to learn in auschwitz and pacquiao
was that those
were most likely to survive with a
strong
meaning orientation an orientation
toward a future task and meaning to
carry out in their lives
and after all in north korea
in japan in north vietnam
the american prisoner of wars
went through the same experience and
my theory has been
confirmed by protein and research
and this is the survival value but i
think that mankind also
has a hope to survive as a whole only
provided that sooner or later
they will come up with common
denominators in axiological terms this
means
with common values with common meanings
to
be shared by people not only but by
peoples
or let me say with a common will
to a common meaning